hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and today's started
the tata steel chess tournament we will
have coverage every day of the
tournament if you're not too familiar
one of the biggest tournaments of the
year has 14 of the top players in the
field we have nine of the top 15 players
in the world playing including the top
three players in the world two of those
are actually up against each other in
round one that we're gonna be covering
white is played by Magnus Carlsen the
number one player in the world he got
second in this tournament last year
looking to get back on the winning track
in 2016 he got first 2015 he got first
decided to take off 2014 but 2013 he got
1st so once to get back into winning
this tournament year after year his
opponent the second ranked player in the
world and that is the American Fabiano
Caruana just coming off winning the
London Classic in December so he's
playing hotter than anyone right now and
this could be a potential future match
of the World Championships as you may
know we have the Canada's tournament
coming up in March and probably on
Caruana will be one of those competitors
to try to win the Canada tournament and
play Magnus Carlsen in November for the
world championship but we'll go ahead
and get into it with Magnus Carlsen and
Fabien our Caruana
magna starts out with his normal efore
move responded pani 5 & 9 f3 and this is
where right away things get a little
interesting with Knight to f6 we just
don't see this very often not sure if
Magnus Carlsen was expecting to see this
I do like the approach from Caruana he
knows Magnus Carlsen wants to come out
the gate this is one of his favorite
tournaments and so he wants to come out
early especially with the white pieces
Magnus tries to be extremely aggressive
and this can many times throw your
opponent off you just don't see Knight
to f6 played after your opponent starts
out with pawn to e4 Knight to f3 I don't
know how many aggressive lines Magnus
Carlsen has to counter this but my guess
is he's not nearly as
prepared for this particular tournament
as he would be against the Berlin
defense which we see many times when we
were seeing that Knight to c6 and then
getting into the right Lopez Berlin
offense from there but man is crossing
continues Knight to e5 this is the
classical variation and then pawn to d6
much better move then the knight coming
and taking here on e4 if you're not too
familiar I do have a video on the petrel
defense you can go and watch that if
you're curious why pawn to d6 even makes
sense pawn to d6 and then the knight
comes back here to f3 now this is two of
the top players in the world myself one
of the moves I like to play when I come
across this is Knight takes on f7
definitely not the most sound move but
depending on who my opponent is this is
a fun way to play chess especially if
you have a fast clock your opponent
plays King to f7 and you can just chase
their King around for a good bit of the
game and I think you can have a
extremely strong game from white it's
very difficult for black to really hold
on to this top level play
that's absolutely going to be a mistake
Magnus Carlsen brings his knight back
here to f3 and the knight takes on e4
both sides are equal in material so
there's a couple ways that Magnus
Carlsen can respond here just completely
avoid the knight on e4 and continue pawn
to d4 this is the most common we see you
could say Knight to c3 if you want
exchange that's fine opens up completely
okay to have double pawns here both
these bishops are ready to go where you
could see even this pawn on d6 is
blocking the start squared Bishop a4
Caruana
so that's another option or it could
just decide let's go ahead and be
aggressive Bishop to b5 check but he
decides to play Queen to e2 it doesn't
matter if he plays pawn to d3 or Queen
to e2 both of these are going to block
the light squared bishop so eventually
Magnus Carlsen will need to move this
weekend as light square bishop involved
in it to the game Queen to e7 stopping
that does a little bit turkey if you try
to hold on to with pawn to f5 so decide
taking a better approach with Queen to
e7 pond III forcing the knight to move
knight comes back here to f6 Knight up
here to c3 continuing development and
then Queen down here to e2 so both sides
seem to be okay getting their queen off
the board especially in the petrov
defense the Queen's coming off generally
ends in a draw game but with these two
you're never really sure play continues
with pawn to g6 getting ready to
fianchetto his bishop here to g7 control
these dark diagonal squares in at the
center of the board Knight to a d4 pawn
to a6 wants to make sure that if the
knight comes to b5 really either these
Knights could come here then blacks not
forced to play Knight to a6 so instead
place pawn to a6 this does now allow the
night to come freely to c6 d7 doesn't
have to worry about a knight coming here
to b5 and then up here to c7 which is a
very very painful square for black to
deal with from here Bishop to f4 Magnus
Carlsen just continuing his development
now I can castle on either side of the
board start to get aggressive with his
rooks Bishop here to g7 as we talked
about pawn h3 just says okay I'll just
continue I don't want to commit to one
side of the board right now and this
does block you from bringing both your
Knights here to g4 as well as your
Bishop here to d4 which you have not
gotten involved into the game right now
and you're probably not gonna be
bringing it to f5 because just the
knight can take it right here
so you may see it to just d7 or even see
six what you still may not want to do
that if you're not willing to exchange
your Bishop a4 of the night so first
move from Caruana after this is Bishop
to d7 Bishop to f3 we're finally able to
to get the light square Bishop involved
after it was blocked by the Queen and
then the pawn came up here to d3 it has
not been doing too much on the board for
Magnus Carlsen Knight to c3 so pretty
much complete the development from both
sides of the board now they can really
decide if they want to castle or not
they don't have to once the Queen's come
the board less likely that sides are
going to Castle unless they have a good
reason to but the night takes here on a
c6 after the bishop takes now black has
a double pawn in the center of the board
not always as bad to have a double pawns
if you have a pawn connected to it and
what I mean by that is well if you have
no pawns on the C file if you have one
here on the D file or the B file not
necessarily as bad because the way you
can exchange you in depth not having
that if this pawn was not here on the D
file this would definitely be a huge
huge weakness for black you could almost
count this as is one one-and-a-half
pawns but we're gonna go and count it as
two for now castle on the Queen side and
then King here to d7 you know black has
the option to castle on the King side if
he wants to but he looks at it and says
my king here on d7 is pretty safe not
only have some of the minor pieces come
off the knight and a bishop the Queen's
not on the board but here on d7 my
opponent can't even attack me with a
light square bishop because it doesn't
exist anymore and so this allows him to
control all these pawns right here this
nights gonna not really attack it
anytime soon and so he can play defense
mode with this King it's involved if he
ever needs to push forward and his rooks
are freely able to go exactly where they
want to since it was here on f8 if they
didn't want to control this efile it
would have to move so since it can
freely move over here King here to d7
much stronger move than try to castle on
the King side Magnus continues with the
rook to e1 just controlling that open
file rook to e8 says yeah let's exchange
if you want to you can imagine a car wan
is completely okay
going against Magnus Carlsen when Magnus
has the white pieces in the first game
to come out with a draw so he's looking
to exchange pieces down he's not playing
you don't play the petrol defense to get
a win you're trying to confuse your
opponent and get to an easy draw game so
that's what we see here rook to e8 says
yeah I don't want you to control this
efile and I'm willing to exchange
material on board
Magnus not necessarily ready to do that
quite yet Knight to e4 blocking that
Knight to d5 attacking
Bishop said the bishop comes back here
to d2 pawn f5 forcing the Knights move
and this brings the pawn to h6 just kind
of dancing around forcing Magnus to
spend a lot of his energy moving his
Knights but at the end of the day
Fabiana Caruana doesn't have any huge
threat that magnus carlsen has to be
worried about pawn to g5 this is a few
moves a few reasons for this move 1 to
make sure he's just putting pressure on
his opponent and also he wants to free
up this bishop here on g7 this Bishop on
d2 Caruana always has to be worried
about because it can attack and take
this pawn on h6 so pawn to g5 says yeah
I'm gonna push forward and I'd no longer
have to worry about this Bishop
defending he can roam free as it needs
to now pawn to c3 upon c5 King up here
to see to just pushing a little bit in
the board Bishop f6 as we talk to you
now I can just get a little bit deeper
into position as it wants to we see an
exchange on the board and now rook to e1
says it's going to exchange if you want
to and now Caruana says yeah I'm not
ready to do that quite yet I'll bring my
rook over here to f8 and so we see rook
to h1 now if you look at this and he say
rook to h1 that's that's sort of an odd
move but there's not a lot of great
squares for Magnus Carlsen to go here
he's not under pressure but how does he
continue there's not a great square for
his bishop he's not gonna bring it back
to c1 he's gonna lose it to the night on
e3 and f4
he could play pawn to g3 that wouldn't
be the worst move if he wanted to
maneuver his knight around he could play
say Knight to g1 and then Knight to e2
maybe g3 if he wants to start attacking
the pawn here at f5 Fabiano has so much
time to respond to that if he wants to
could on the Queen side of the board
pawn to a3 is an option but he decides
rukh to h1 and part of that is depending
on how magnus carlsen continues with
some of the exchanges he could have an
attack with his rook here instead of
trying to have it on this efile
both sides are extremely even in this
position it's tough to see how either
side will come out victorious unless
someone it does make a huge mistake rook
here to e8 attacking this open file pawn
to g3 pawn down here we start to see the
knight come back to G 1 and then the
bishop comes down here to g5 so Caruana
being pretty aggressive on board but
then King down here to d1 says if my
bishops going to move I need to have a
stop for the rook coming down here to e1
which could be a very very problematic
Square for white to deal with right now
bishop holding down that so says he I
don't mind what in exchange with the
bishops but I do want to hold on to that
with my King here on a t1
Ponte a5 pushing on the Queen side
doesn't have a lot of support on the
Queen side but it doesn't have much else
going on so decides to start pushing
there Knight to e2
pawn to a4 and then the bishops exchange
on the board and then after pawn to g4
and a recapture you can start to see
what Magnus calcium was going for when
he played rook here to H 1 now this is
the situation where we have double pawns
on the G file this is not good for
Caruana you can't really think of this
as two pawn moves because they don't
support each other in any way shape or
form it's very easy for your opponent to
start to attack especially this pawn
behind here on g5 so Magnus Carlsen
continues with rook to h5 that's hacking
that rook down here a five supporting
that rook h7 check King to e6 now the
night here on a d5 is protecting that
pawn so the rooks not going to take it
yet pawn here to a3 rook to f5 pawn to
c4 so this is forcing the knight to move
and this Knight is protecting the square
here honest he's seven but the knight
comes up here attacks on f6 and the rook
decides to come back to h2 not looking
to take that material right now he could
have though if you're looking and here's
can you take this rook with this pawn on
c7 absolutely can just doesn't want to
have to worry about his apartment
playing rook takes on f2 so that's why
in this position decides to bring his
rook back here to HT protecting this
pond he thinks that's more valuable than
taking this pawn back here on a c7 which
is double pawn structure onto the
sea-fowl he thinks he can attack that
later on where he has the better pawn
structure no reason to give your
opponents a non double pawn in exchange
for coming down here and wrecking your
second rank here which is always
problematic for white so rook down to f3
King here to c2 Knight to d7 both sides
just moving a little bit trying to get a
better position in the center of the
board pawn up here to d4 Knight to b6
attacking the pawn pawn takes here on to
c5 we do see an exchange so you can see
this is what magnus carlsen wants double
pawns on both the C foul and the G file
with no support so this is going to be
good
Knight to c3 King here to e5 in the
center of the board Knight down here to
d1 and from here we actually see a drawn
game now it's somewhat weird if you look
at this and say the knight is attacking
this square here on c4 why does the
knight come down here to d1 for Magnus
Carlsen and Fabiana caruana decides to
to draw right now it's gonna be tough
for either these sides to really get a
victory here you would have to make a
huge mistake I think both of the sides
recognize this they're already at 41
moves they haven't spent a ton of energy
having gone down any crazy lines where
they're getting mentally fatigued I
think both of the players just
recognized hey let's not get too crazy
here we're the number one two players in
the world we don't want to have a
marathon session of 4050 extra moves so
let's just go ahead and call it a day
now if it was can or to continue
maybe the knight takes here on c4 yes
black has more material but as we talked
about you you don't always count these
as full pawns because it's very
difficult to really take it
of both of the ponds through work coming
up here to h5 attacking this depending
on where Pony goes maybe King comes over
here to to f5 to hold on to it
rook up here h7 pawn to c6 Magnus
Carlsen has ways to attack back rook
over here to a7 can really put pressure
either these pawns if you want to take
the pawn here or even come back here to
a c7 so has some options all-in-all this
did not play out but this is how it
could have if they continued so great
game from Magnus Carlsen probably O'Hara
wanna to get this party started
Tata Steel's tournament it's gonna be
going on for a couple weeks so we will
have a ton of games with 14 of the top
players in the world going on for a
couple weeks we should have some amazing
games so hope you guys are excited about
this tournament thank you for tuning in
to round one and I'll catch you tomorrow
for round number two